I would go to the sack if I get what I get.
Future needs origin.
When I was 6 years old,
I refused to wear my headscarf to a girls' school
in Iran and I just threw it away.
My parents knew we had to leave the country.
And so began my journey that took me to Germany.
With Miss Germany,
I would like to encourage young women with Migrationshintergrund
to become the best version of themselves,
to be strong,
to think big so that they can achieve their dreams.
Origin,
I am Iranian.
I will never forget where I come from.
I will always stand up for the rights of women in Iran who take
to the streets and demonstrate and fight for their freedom.
Future,
I am German.
I was allowed to grow up here in freedom,
attend university and start a German-Iranian family.
I got to be an architect in a man's world as a little foreign
girl and today I lead 1 architecture team with projects
in the most beautiful places in the world.
Integration works when we understand where we are,
when we know where we want to go,
and when we never,
never forget where we come from.
To the young women with Migrationshintergrund out there,
I'd like to say Dream Big.
And to my courageous sisters I would like to say San sendigie,
that is,
Woman Life Freedom.